in this video Sabertooth starts killing
the X-Men and yes this takes place in
the main Marvel Universe it is not in an
alternate reality so this opens up with
Sabertooth killing Cyclops while he's
being watched by both Wolverine and an
entire audience of multiversal versions
of himself so what in the world is going
on here okay so here's the thing the
last video that we covered for
saber-tooth in Marvel Comics was kind of
the followup to when he had been thrown
in the pit in the mutant nation of kcoa
literally where all the X-Men in those
guys lived the pit was basically a
prison but saber-tooth had realized he
could control the prison and then
eventually he could leave the prison and
so along with other mutants that had
been thrown down there he essentially
freed himself and then they ended up
taking off in a story called saber-tooth
and the Exiles which we haven't covered
yet in that story his son Gren Creed
which is actually the result of
sabertooth and Mystique having a son
that Gren Creed had just been traveling
the Multiverse killing all these
different versions of sabertooth and he
finally got his hands on the main
Sabertooth told him what he'd been doing
and then the main Sabertooth along with
all the other sabertooths that hadn't
been killed yet ended up basically
grabbing Gren Creed and throwing him
into some alternate reality but that's
why we're here right now not only that
this Wolverine that you see is not
actually Wolverine instead it's a
version of sabertooth from Earth
33441 and his name is camo basically he
can turn into seemingly anybody now the
thing about this is this guy looks like
he has powers that are very similar to
copycat but even Sabertooth makes this
statement right he says you even got the
scent right no one would know that it
was not Wolverine I bet your thoughts
even sound like his and he says still
trying to figure out how you're doing it
it's more than just mimicry it's like
you're rewiring my mind now if I were a
betting man I would say that Cam's
abilities are almost identical to
copycat for those of you guys who don't
know who copycat is do you remember in
the Deadpool movie Ryan Reynolds
girlfriend Vanessa that's copycat
Technically she's not copycat in the
movie but in the comics she's like
Mystique except she's better which is to
say Mystique can just physically turn
and look like somebody else copycat
copies them down to the genetic level
and can even duplicate their powers she
cannot turn into animals but Mystique
can which begs the question if copycat
turns into Mystique can she then turn
around and turn into animals I don't
know but the important thing here is
this seems to be the reason why this guy
was able to duplicate Wolverine and even
smell like Wolverine right so by all
standards of measurement he was that guy
the other thing about this is that
saber-tooth is a man on a mission the
consistent theme with his character ever
since he was thrown into the pit during
the beginning of house and powers of X
and then his Escape during the events of
the original saber-tooth miniseries
after house and powers of X is that he's
been trying to destroy the quiet Council
basically get revenge on the people who
had thrown him into the pit itself the
result is that when he ended up
liberating all these multiversal
versions of himself his idea was we're
going to go kill the X-Men but in order
for you guys to understand what you're
getting into we're going to kill the
X-Men in your universe so you can at
least get some idea of what they're
capable of the X-Men here are a lot more
capable than the ones that you're used
to dealing with not only that we're
going to a place where every mutant
that's in existence or most every mutant
in existence on Earth is located in
because one of the things to understand
is that by the time the events of the
fall of exit happened the attack on kcoa
mutants being scattered to the wind
saber-tooth was already gone he has no
idea that's happened he doesn't know any
of that's happened right as far as he's
concerned mutants are still just living
on ccoa and doing their thing but the
important thing here here is there are
hundreds of them there so you don't just
walk into ccoa and start massacring
people so a lot of this is more or less
training them getting to understand
what's going on at that point you switch
over to the North Pole and we end up
picking up with xforce now the reason
for this is because historically as part
of house and powers of X xforce was kind
of like the Black Ops wet workor team of
the X-Men right they go in they do some
really seedy stuff they end up coming
out but it's kind of one of those do
whatever you have to do to accomplish
the mission by any means necessary right
that kind of thing but following the
whole circumstance where Beast had
basically gone aai and then wanted to
destroy humanity and so on and so forth
they'd more or less been on the run
right that also comes off the heels of
the fall of X where they're more or less
operating and hiding of course you have
black Tom Cassidy who controls plants
and that guy really kind of sets up a
sort of perimeter around the area and
then you have Quinton choir now Quinton
choir is really like definitively one of
the three most powerful telepaths on
Earth I would say one of the four right
like you're talking about Gan gray and
Professor Xavier Exodus and Quinton
choir right like their telepathy is off
the charts but what's going on here is
they're having this conversation about
the
250,000 mutants that were just sent off
the island of kkaa by Professor Xavier
when the events of fall of X kicked off
right that whole thing took place in
Immortal X-Men we covered it in our
coverage of the X-Men Comics there'll be
a link to the playlist at the end of
this if you need to get caught up but
they're all on their way back the
problem with this is they'll end up
coming back through kakaa but as we know
ever since the end of fall of X the
whole island is surrounded by Sentinels
if they show up there it's going to be a
bloodbath right it's going to be an
absolute Massacre and even if the
Sentinels are destroyed by these 250,000
mutants you can imagine half of their
number would be eradicated at the very
least right probably more than that and
so what you end up getting is Quinton
choir who takes it on himself to
basically travel to the island of kcoa
and then effectively turn it into a
place where mutants can get through and
then leave right not stay there but just
kind of remove the Sentinel threat
that's around there and call it a day
right kind of make it a place where they
can pass through while he's doing that
Sabertooth and his guys are all heading
towards Earth and when they get there of
course using a cloaking device so they
cannot be detected by these dozens of
Sentinels that are floating around that
they end up realizing ing the entire
place is empty right like saber-tooth
even comments to himself he says this is
not how the island looked when I was a
prisoner in the pit let's take a closer
look personal cloaking devices for the
landing party and as they look around
Sabertooth comes to the realization
people cleared out in a rush whatever
happened on kcoa was not sweet the
mutants didn't just decide to leave they
fled and so one of the things that I
want you guys to notice here and it's
one of the coolest things that Marvel's
doing with saber-tooth historically
speaking Sabertooth especially when
you're talking about the Chris Claremont
era back in like the 80s he was a
Mindless Beast or not really mindless
but he was just like a feral just
violent psychotic being that was out
there right I mean I'll tell you right
now like the old school 1980 Sabertooth
was absolutely insane I mean this it was
amazing the kind of stories that you got
with that guy in more recent years they
toned him down and made him a little
more intelligent what this is doing is
blending the two right all the
experience the battle hardened
experiences that he's had and all that
kind of stuff it all comes together to
combine with his ferocious nature to
make him just a absolute force of Nature
and so that's why he figures out like
that that basically something happened
here and everything went sideways now in
the midst of all of this Quinton choir
shows up and then he realizes that these
Sentinels basically have psionic
dampening abilities basically they can
kind of scramble his tele telepathic
Powers he can't focus the way that he
needs to so he can't really use his
psychic abilities to overcome these
things but once he looks down he comes
to the realization that wolver rain's
down there and initially he takes it as
a fence right because he told black Tom
Cassidy don't worry about getting a hold
of wolver rain I can do it on my own but
when he gets down to the island he
realizes it's not wolver rain because
out of the direct influence of the
Sentinels his telepathic abilities come
back and that's when we find out it's
camo the guy plunges his claws through
the neck of Quenton choir they whisk him
back to the ship if you want to call it
that of the sabertooths and they
immediately start tearing him apart
right this is happening in the main
Marvel Universe again like Quinton
choire has just been killed off one of
the most powerful telepaths in Marvel
has just been killed by Sabertooth at
that point you jump back to the North
Pole this time you pick up with dcon
technically he's going by the name
akihiro which is fine but like it's daon
Fang any number of names you want to
call him dark Wolverine whatever it's
all basically the same thing but there's
a kind of bonding moment that's
happening between himself and wolver
rain now he's also joined by Rico also
known as scorpion boy basically he's a
mutant whose power makes him look like
an actual scorpion but there's a kind of
bonding moment between the two because
wolver rain in a lot of ways kind of
greets Deon as a son and that's kind of
how things have been going for a little
while but this is a very tumultuous
thing and the reason why is
understanding the history between
between the two daon never knew his
father and in fact daon believed that
wolver rain was like a straightup
villain right like he wanted to kill his
dad more so than that he was a pure
villain in his early appearances the old
stories involving like the dark X-Men
during like dark rain and all that kind
of stuff but the Journey of daon over
the years has been one of redemption the
problem with this is that Marvel has
been so back and forth and so
inconsistent on how they handle his
character that it's just one of those
things where he kind of free floats
right right and he's just kind of left
to the whims and the desires of whoever
it is that happens to be writing the
story at the time more so than that that
he basically tells them like you know
get to butchering on this Caribou that
I've brought here and then I'm going to
go back do you know some checking around
on the you know make the rounds all that
kind of stuff make sure everything's
cool when I get back we'll Feast we'll
laugh you know and then we'll go to
sleep that kind of thing and so what he
does is he gets inside the main base of
xforce and he has this really really
cool monologue right and people who know
about the history between Sabertooth and
Wolverine immediately know what he's
about to talk about because what he says
here is we had more than a home in ccoa
we had a nation a family both biological
and chosen daon Laura Scout Xavier Jean
Sage Quinton choir together we had a
shot at happiness maybe saber-tooth
factored into that Creed was thrown in
the pit my greatest enemy for almost as
far back as I can remember at every
Point saber-tooth was a part of the
worst of it for once in my very long
life I didn't have that constant
creeping dread that Sabertooth was just
over my shoulder ready to wreak havoc
that all Came Crashing Down When orcus
attacked the Hellfire Gala and most of
mutant kind ended up dead or exiled this
North Pole base the greenhouse is what
remains I'm doing the best I can to
protect it and so that's when he meets
with sage and he meets with uh black Tom
Cassidy and what they reveal is that
they have basically set up a kind of
perimeter around the whole area right so
no one is going to get in there without
them knowing that they're there more so
than that Sage picks up on the idea that
wolver rain's worried about something in
particular she doesn't really know what
it is but she knows that something's a
little off now this is the cruel moment
here because this is something that
Marvel has not focused on for quite some
time and I'm so glad to see they brought
it back what they end up doing here is
they say Creed was banished in the pit
in the dark belly of kcoa supposedly
he's still there because Wolf Rain
doesn't know that saber-tooth got out
and he says but for a short time I'd
been dragged down to the same prison my
memories are ragged I know his stain was
there like a nightmare programmed into
the Island's DNA but I don't recall all
encountering him otherwise it's enough
to make a guy paranoid especially on
this of all nights Sabertooth had this
sick tradition of bringing me pain for
my birthday now here's the reason why
that's so cool is because for the
longest time in Marvel Comics one
Wolverine and saber-tooth were just
straight up pure enemies but for the
longest time every year on his birthday
Sabertooth would kill someone close to
Wolverine whether it be a lover a wife a
friend a teammate it didn't matter but
he would literally kill them and then
Wolverine would discover the corpse he
would realize it was Sabertooth he would
go to the fight saber-tooth would just
be waiting for him and the two of them
would have this knockdown drag out fight
back in the 80s they were just brutal
fights more recently it's just kind of
like cats scratching at each other but
now we're getting to like some real
really dark stuffed here because what
happens is saber-tooth forces bring a
device that seemingly holds the actual
brain of Quinton choir and the reason
why I say that is because they fire off
this kind of energy blast at the island
which neutralizes black Tom Cassidy and
Sage but because their eyes light up it
looks more like telepathic influence so
literally they channel the power of one
of the most powerful telepaths in the
world and use it to shut down the
defense system and so following that you
basically switch over to uh d himself as
he's going through and essentially
butchering this caribou and he kind of
has this little bit of a conversation
with scorpion boy right where he says
that Logan and I we've had our rough
spots that's probably an understatement
they literally tried to kill each other
and I'm pretty sure daon succeeded in
killing him at one point right when wol
went to hell but he says we've both done
terrible things to each other is more
accurate things were okay on kcoa but
something about that place I don't know
it felt like forcing a hug right now's
different right now we actually need
each other not just me and him either
but all of us do you know what I mean
right now when he asked that question
scorpion boy has these two hands that
just rip through his chest and literally
Sabertooth tears him in half and he
tells daon it's midnight you know what
that means and and I'm here to give the
run a gift he'll never forget and this
guy tears daon apart literally because
what happens is Wolverine comes back
right Wolverine gets back here to the
campsite and he asks him right daon like
did you get that butchering done and the
answer is I mean yeah but not really in
the way that you think because Wolverine
my friend it wasn't the Caribou that was
butchered it was dayon because
saber-tooth his guys are waiting on him
and his son was literally Torn to Pieces
and his body parts laid out in such a
way that it spells happy birthday it's
gruesome and amazing with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end because this comic comes
out twice a month so the next issue
comes out either this coming week or the
week after if you guys need to get
caught up on fall of X saber-tooth all
that stuff make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later
peace